welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and miss marvel makes major
contributions to the marvel cinematic
universe with kamala khan a super fan of
captain marvel who through a family
heirloom bengal acquires the power to
cast hard light hard light sounds like a
type of beer when i was a kid i tried to
request at a college party before i knew
what beer was um does that cake have a
hard light in it okay i'll leave it
remains a mystery what exactly this hard
light is whether it comes from an
extraterrestrial source or something
rooted in kabbalah's pakistani heritage
also a mystery why they had to change it
for kamala's in-beginning powers in the
comics but i can tell you my friends
this series is already telling us and my
interview with the directors has
confirmed that there is actually a lot
more to this story and i think we're
about to hear some magical words of
inhumans and pterogenesis yes this girl
is connected to this dude i'm gonna
explain how now the best way you can
support what we do here at new rockstars
is to check out our miss marvel inspired
cosmic daydream i love this design when
you get this you'll get the added option
to write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of our miss marvel
after shows so i interviewed adil and
bilal the awesome dudes who directed the
first and the final episodes of the
season and i asked them specifically
about kamala's power set and i was so
surprised how much they revealed how
much can you talk about where exactly
her powers come from so when we came on
the project there was this you know
heart it was described as hard light and
with the production team and the visual
effects we really wanted to capture the
the spirit of the of the comic book so
you still have you know those aspects of
the you know the beacon hand or you know
when when when she's not in control of
her power and like her body's changing
as a teenager but you know if you go
further in the episodes she's gonna get
more and more control over power and and
then it's gonna evolve and in the last
episode is the real deal yo that's the
real deal
yeah so a major takeaway here kamala's
powers are still evolving we have not
yet seen her final form which they
described as the real deal so backing up
a little here in the marvel comics are a
subset of characters called inhumans
they were created by the cree you know
the advanced alien race from the captain
marvel film known for being
imperialistic [ __ ] prick
thousands of years ago the cree
experimented on the humans of earth
exposing them to technology called
terrigen mist which causes one to be
enveloped in a cocoon and then come out
of it with superpowers this process is
called pterogenesis this is how we got
black bolt medusa carnac maximus all the
other inhumans seen on that short lived
in humans marvel tv series on abc
terrorism missed krietek and inhumans
were also a big part of agents of shield
daisy went through terror genesis and
came out as quake with seismic powers
doctor strange and multiverse of man has
just established that onsen molt's black
bolt same actor from the inhuman series
exists in the 838 universe as quote
keeper of the terrigen mist just the
fact that they use that term is a very
big deal especially when we consider
multiverse of madness was the mcu title
directly preceding ms marvel now in the
2014 miss marvel comics that this series
is based on kamala khan gets her powers
after exposure from the terrigen mist
she is in a sense an inhuman leading up
to this there was a conflict between
thanos and black bolt thanos came to
earth looking for his son and black
bolts like get the f out of here and
obviously didn't use those words
so black bolt detonates a terrigen bomb
that causes the mist to flow into jersey
city where it hits kamala by the way the
first episode of ms marvel snuck in a qr
code on the atm and bruno's circle
hughes shop where if you scan it it
takes you to that 2014 miss marvel
number one where you can read the
storyline yourself for free also we
should note that that same mist hits
komron who also becomes an inhuman with
the power of bioiluminescence and komron
will now appear in the show as kamala's
crush but like all things that transform
there's probably more than meets the eye
but anyway when kamala goes into her
terrigen cocoon she sees visions of her
favorite avengers captain marvel captain
america iron man and as a particular fan
of carol danvers she exits a cocoon
looking like carol caucasian with blonde
hair but with stretchy limbs and she
rescues zoe zimmer by embiggening her
hand and catching her shortly after this
kamala realizes she can just look like
herself which is how we get the
superhero kamala khan in the marvel
comics now the disney plus series has
yet to confirm how exactly the
live-action version of kamala fits into
all that and while we do see her in
beginning hand catching zoe zimmer this
episode some fans are still scratching
their heads as to why the series is
depicting her powers as hard light
instead of just her arms enhanced in
beginning is marvel studios turning
kamala khan into green lantern for no
reason no no no i very much think marvel
studios is going to confirm kamala khan
as an inhuman the byproduct of kree
technology and they're just doing it in
a more grounded and spiritual way it is
an adaptation from the comics and i
think it is the right move see with
every mcu title especially origin
stories the powers the hero uses in the
first act of the story are rarely their
final form as was this case with tony
stark and the first iron man and even
with juana maximov in one division good
stories are about characters who change
over the course of the story and this is
what the directors are referring to by
evolving and the real deal when kamala
first clips on that bangle a layer of
light coats over her body and then she
drops into another realm before coming
right back out of it with the ability to
cast light as she is wearing her captain
marvel cosplay this hard light by the
way is not the sturdiest stuff in the
world it dissipates at random it
crumbles when bullets are fired at it so
i think that layer of light whisping
over her arms the realm she dropped into
and the hard light that she now projects
all represent the terrigen mist and the
cocoon and they are temporary the hard
light i believe are pieces of that
cocoon that she is shedding off like
scales and flakes and eventually she
will deplete this hard light revealing
her new evolved form underneath it which
will look something closer to the real
deal stretchy kamala khan comics readers
know and love but this video is brought
to you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light and sleek and industrial it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky old school wallets
and make you look like you're smuggling
an 80s car phone in your back pocket
check it out there are over 30 colors
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash card
and gold
dollars this is what they call the black
damascus only the finest for my front
pockets every ridge wallet comes with a
lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it the wallets have over 40 000 5 star
reviews it's made with an rfid blocking
technology that protects you from those
digital pickpocketers they also have
other cool products like this commuter
backpack it's weatherproof and great for
toting around a laptop this month
actually marks nine years since the
ridge started and they're celebrating
with a special sale so get 15 percent
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description the hard
light is just her subconscious crumbly
paper mache looking cosplay imitation of
the powers of carol danvers because
kamala at that moment was dressed like
carol danvers when this activation
occurred this is all taking the form of
wish fulfillment 11 11 on the side of
her home when she got home 11 11 the
time of day one makes a wish the hard
light is just what kamala thinks she
wants but it is not her final form in
fact in the closing credits the graffiti
even shows an actual kamala khan in big
and hand catching zoe no hard light
there just the real deal so why did they
change it from the comics i'm only
speaking for myself here i can't speak
on behalf of the show or the cast for
marvel studios but i think this series
just needed to invent a transitional
stage a kamala's pterogenesis that was
not a pakistani american girl changing
her body into that of a white woman i
get it i love the comics the themes of
kamala's self-image works so well in the
pages of those comics g willow wilson
wrote an amazing story but think about
it disney plus were to drop a trailer in
the first few episodes of a very high
profile episodic week by week disney
plus streaming series all of these
titles hyper analyzed by social media
who do not wait for nuance and are just
craving for a reason to complain and
cancel something that would have been a
tough sell both for the actress to cast
his kamala khan or for whatever
caucasian extras they cast if that is
the reason i totally understand the
producers and casts not wanting to try
to explain that so they had to come up
with some kind of transitory middle step
one that they can evolve past but one
that still looks cool and fun to play
with in the meantime and that my friends
is hard light a cosmic form of cosplay
it looks like glowing paper mache that
kamala wears over her body and yeah it
looks pretty cool i think they did a
pretty good job if that was their goal
but looking ahead at the series if we
assume that kamala is in the middle of
her terror genesis process to complete
that evolution since this bangle was
given to her by her maternal grandmother
hernani kamala will have to reconnect
with her family roots in pakistan
because when she first entered that
cocoon remember she was surrounded by
dozens of shadowy figures she did not
see carol danvers or cap or tony like
she did in the comics she saw rose and
rose of faceless heroes i think the
visual parallels with the ancestral
plane are not by accident because like
t'challa seeing shadowy panthers who
represented his ancestors i think these
faces kamala's true heroes will be
revealed to be her pakistani ancestors
with hernani being revealed as a cree
tech formed inhuman as well this nani
was the daydreamer who kamala's mother
muniba broke away from to come to
america and when i asked the directors
about muniba having speed powers which
was probably just a joke in the episode
they did have this interesting answer
well i i mean for us we see that her mom
and the father and actually her family
and friends that those are the real
superpowers of kamala khan in in our
opinion these are the real
a little avengers group you know that
so there you go kamala begins this
season embarrassed by her father who
wants to cosplay as the hulk and i think
she's gonna end this season really proud
of him and who knows maybe this guy even
has actual strength powers like he did
mention how he doesn't check his mirrors
when he drives is this guy actually
invulnerable i think we are looking at a
whole family of inhumans all part of
kamala's bloodline descending from anani
who i think became an inhuman after some
experiments by those [ __ ] cree yes
they're still [ __ ] but they do give
us some pretty cool [ __ ] and that is how
she is connected to him just be glad he
didn't ask him because his breath is
terrible we will see as the season goes
but i want to hear your thoughts on this
comment down below follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstar subscribe to rockstar some more
analysis of everything you love thank
you for watching bye
[Music]
you